hello I'm the Nostalgia Critic I
remember it so you don't have to and
perhaps some of you remember the last
video I posted where I threatened the
Angry Video Game Nerd to stop his fans
from making unfair comparisons to me so
please leave this petty jealous rage
behind you and simply acknowledge that
I'm the better man
if you accept this defeat please respond
by leaving absolutely no comment
whatsoever well I Got News for You
faithful viewers the Angry Video Game
Nerd has responded on his forum which
still counts he responded unto the forum
topic nostalgia critic calls out angry
video game nerd you got some balls buddy
you just couldn't leave it alone could
you
you just had to leave a comment about my
video ditcher well you want to keep this
going on game of your game so let's see
what threatening words the Angry Video
Game Nerd has to throw at me
the forum common reads and I quote I've
seen some of his videos his Cloverfield
review was hilarious and if I'm not
mistaken I think he did the 5-second
movies also those put me to tears so yes
call me a fan of his what am I supposed
to do that that's not a threat that's up
up what's that word I never give anybody
um a compliment you can't give me a
compliment you're an angry video game
they're not the emotionally aware video
game nerd I see what you're trying to do
yeah you're trying to one-up me aren't
you
you're trying to look like the big
better man with deep down inside you
hate me just as much as I hate you well
I know how you think if I'm not mistaken
there is a hidden message inside of this
comment a message that secretly sending
me a dirty insult and I intend to find
it up right now the comment was posted
March 13th 2008 313
and eight what could they meet perhaps
letters of alphabet of course three is
see their team would be M 20 would be T
and eight would be H that's almost two
weeks into March 14 days the Ides of
March clever bastard so that be n
there's 38 words in the message third
eight words divide by two weeks is 19
which we s Cloverfield implies a field
of clovers clovers have the same number
of letters as Jehovah Jehovah J but in
the Latin alphabet Jehovah begins with
an i five second movies times the three
minutes it takes me to make them is
equal to 15 Oh leading us back to the
Kennedy assassination opening up the
kingdom of the Crystal Skull which means
that Mario Lopez is a woman
da Vinci knew about this and left
secrets for us to find everything comes
back to the number 23 wait no it's just
a coincidence only the strangers can
lead us to paradise it's all part of the
illusion
who are you
when my were all monkeys the clues are
said I just have to crack the code
okay after a really long time of
investigating I think I finally figured
out the secret of the message and so the
angry video game nerd message translates
out to piss I'm get sooo sit Turk I
Glasson
which isn't German is a Latin it isn't
Gaelic which means it's total gibberish
I just wasted hours and hours of
research to come up with absolutely
nothing true and discovered an
untraceable pattern in the stock market
that would lead to nothing but higher
returns but that's inconsequential I'm
wasting my life dedicated everything to
complete bullshit I mean look at me look
at me I like a road map for dizzy people
I guess he really had nothing bad to say
at all and here I wore my thinking wait
for nothing I guess the angry video game
nerd really is the better man
I guess it's best just to acknowledge
that in a world of vengeance anger and
chaos there are those who can always
find the peaceful route and in the end
maybe that's the essence of all mankind